how did you transition from the military
to leaving that to go into property when
you're undervalued it squashes you and
you're buying properties putting High
rents selling it to them is awesome how
much do you expect to make per month in
the next six months I think by month six
we're going to be in excess of 20 000.
you're like one of the most hard-working
people ever how many deals have you sold
in the last year in excess of 20. you
have to be absolutely Relentless and you
really have to want it you operate as if
you've been in the game 20 years but
actually all of the risk factors
involved I've been quite obsessed with
Ross from the military transitioned into
property now making how much on average
a month well over the last 30 days I've
earned 12 000 pounds and that's profit
profit well I've got my off takes are
around 300. absolutely awesome what do
you mean 300 pounds what's that your
software and cramps
takes a few fuel expenses did you think
a year ago that you'd be able to make 12
Grand in a month no absolutely not what
were you making if you don't mind me
asking in the military
um so my take home was two and a half
thousand pounds a month okay it's wow
which is an average salary it's a decent
salary so tell me Ross how did you
transition from the military to leaving
that to go into property what's your
story what happened because I know we're
going to get a lot of gems inspiration
from the from this interview I was
always trying to live a life that I
couldn't afford
I was always you know my mother always
said you know champagne lifestyle
lemonade wages it was a bit of a running
joke in the family I didn't just sit
down and and complain about it I did try
things I tried Drop Shipping for example
that didn't that didn't work out for me
um believe it or not during covert I
actually imported a lot of geodesic
domes for covert so everyone could have
for corporate events everyone would have
their own bubble you know I thought that
could be something to jump when I
invested quite heavily into that my dad
and I used to travel around the North
East setting setting up these domes
um
I ended up losing quite a lot of money
on that as well
um and then I was actually deployed in
support of the Ukraine crisis and during
my downtime I started watching YouTube
videos found some of your leads and uh
and from there I was hooked it was
actually one video in particular which
is why I chose you as a mentor and it
was actually the
um the one where you were accused of
being a fake Guru yeah and I remember
watching them thinking what a difficult
situation to be and he was in your home
you know he was calling me these things
and actually the way that you responded
to that I thought was quite inspiring
what was it about my response because if
I remember I just sort of
absolutely destroyed him yeah well it
was just that the the professional
manner that you did it in yeah you know
you could could have quite easily lost
your head but I thought you handled that
very well so that made you think
actually maybe this it's funny how like
negativity like someone coming into my
house saying you're a fake Guru
challenging me having all these
questions trying to do a hit piece on me
and then that kind of people are like
wanting to watch it because they're
interested but then it ends up people
like you watching it and going actually
and now we're working together and do
deals together that's really interesting
so so you tried lots of different things
in the pursuit of making more money and
then you came down to my one pound crash
course then what happened next I was
hooked we went down to London for a
further educational training course it
was all it was an All or Nothing
situation I was all in I was committed
and I was prepared to sacrifice things
um for success and I was you know I was
desperately trying to leave the military
at the time why were you so desperate to
leave the military because after 17
years I was undervalued underpaid really
struggling to progress I had a further
three years to serve for a full pension
so if I had served the further three
years I would have left with a a huge
you know lump sum of money and then paid
for the rest of my life but actually I
couldn't even face the final three years
really I couldn't I couldn't do it
because when you're undervalued
it squashes you and I couldn't stand it
any longer so I threw myself into
the academy but then you did regret the
decision I did so I I felt like I had an
aptitude for it quite quickly so I
picked it up I felt as though
I knew what I was doing things were
rolling well picked up to it like a duct
of water yeah I felt it so I was doing
everything right well I became compliant
um started a website everything that I
did was professional yeah I was working
for free in many regards you know making
hundreds of phone calls connecting with
people networking following the training
and things weren't going my way you know
so I called the academy and said look
guys I'm struggling I had some
motivational words and and things did
start to improve sometimes it's not
about
over analyzing what you're doing it is
just a time thing if you can gain
people's trust in you know in the
industry
then you're on for a winner but
sometimes it's a little bit of just
serve your time how did you feel when
you were doing everything that you were
told to do and then it wasn't working
and you weren't getting results
yeah it's it's difficult it's difficult
but you've got the network to lean on I
mean I've got hundreds of new friends
hundreds of new friends created from
from the academy we all lean on each
other
and together you end up finding what
works I think ultimately the key is
finding a niche in the market becoming a
specialist yeah
um
you know having that having that real
understanding for what you're doing and
I can't wait to delve into your Niche
because you're like one of the most
hard-working people ever you're very
militant in style you'll you'll take
something you'll run with it and that's
why I think you're so successful now
you've mastered you know BR you've
mastered deal sourcing you've mastered
how to build a relationships with estate
agents and that's why you're so
successful but I think it's very
interesting the transition
and even the mental transition from you
going from military
to property how was it transitioning
it was tough uh it was tough you have to
be absolutely Relentless and you really
have to want it you really have to want
it I think joining the academy is one
thing but you really need to to want do
you know when you had a call with Tony
and you were saying like I think I want
to quit this I just I want my money back
I've changed my mind
what do you think would have happened if
Tony had just been like all right no
problem see you later like because Tony
kicked your ass didn't they he did you
did and that's exactly what I needed
what did he say on the phone he asked me
if I knew everything about property
right you know it was a bit of a
rhetorical question yeah I don't know
anything about Robert and I said well no
of course not he says well get a grip
get a grip of yourself and and and push
on you know yeah yeah and that's exactly
what I needed to hear and I really have
grinded a really hard yeah Relentless
how many deals have you sold in the last
year in the last year in excess of 20 I
think it was 22. and last month you sold
four but how much are you charging on
average for a fee between three and four
thousand that's working all right Twelve
Grand yeah but that's like a serious
income yeah and also you're buying
houses yourself yeah what have you got
going on for yourself so I've used the
money generated from deal sourcing to
buy my own bro oh you've bought it now
yeah all right completely today
completed today your dad's collecting
the keys right now oh mate
congratulations cheers I didn't even
know that
yeah and well how much you pay for it so
it's actually uh I got it for one five
eight we're gonna spend around 25 and
gdv220 and you know your figures well
because it's bread and butter for you
it's what you do so then what's the
refurbs then you'll refinance it well
actually what I've done is I've actually
bought this on a residential okay and
the plan is to live in it if it's a flip
obviously the capital gains you know
I'll I'll save on a couple of games if
I've lived in the property yeah so the
flip is an option there if not with the
equity I've built in the property I can
refinance on to buy to let it's a really
good strategy that Ross because you you
presumably you didn't put down a massive
deposit how much did you have to put
down uh ten percent of the one of the
158 yeah so you bought it for one five
eight you only have to put down about 15
16 Grand and then you're gonna div it up
with a refurb and then you can either
sell it and make a nice profit of 50
Grand or something and pay zero tax
or get a new mortgage and get your
deposit back and go again well I've
actually placed it on a Tracker mortgage
which means there's no oh secret
refinances straight away
yeah that's smart yeah what is a Tracker
mortgage a Tracker mortgage is where
you're not fixed into a term right so if
if for example I chose a two-year fixed
term
if I completed the refurb let's say
after six months and and refinanced at
that point I would be charged quite
heavily for exiting the mortgage during
that term with a Tracker
uh there's no early repayment charges
essentially it's still a two-year term
but you've got the flexibility to
remortgage exit you know whatever you
whatever you trust right
how did you go from not knowing loads
about property or having any properties
experience to now be one of the most
trusted deal sources in the academy
having people ask your opinion on
mortgages fixed rate trackers refurbs
you're not just you're not just
packaging selling deals you're project
managing the process you're connecting
them with housing associations like you
operate as if you've been in the game 20
years but you've only been in the game a
year yeah but how how have you done that
so quickly I just think the guys that
normally know that I'm
quite intense quite quite OCD in some
ways in my Approach yeah and I don't
ever advise or or help on matters that I
have no understanding of yeah so I've
spent an awful lot of time with
commercial broker
uh an awful long time just sat with
agents and law firms and and really
started to understand the market you
know and interestingly I'm sure we'll
touch on and you know from from from
private hmos looking at the comparison
then to social housing here I found that
quite interesting we'll talk about that
100 but actually all of the risk factors
involved are being quite obsessed with
so
showing a client a deal but actually
saying well look here's some pinch
points you may you know would need to
address and we need to get our docs in a
row before we progress to purchase and
yeah I think you're going to really
understand what you're getting into yeah
and I've got the respect for the client
in that they're the ones investing
hundreds of thousands of pounds and it's
my duty and responsibility to make sure
that that's been done yeah with limited
risk last month we saw four deals yeah
who are the investors where do they come
from so I would I would say at the
moment it's it's about a 75 25 split
between Academy and then just people who
found me online nice it's a 75 being
your Academy members and 25 being and
because they're on the academy they know
that you're registered you've got pims
covering yeah if there's any issues you
will mediate you've also got the
familiarity where you you see them every
Monday but also you're building your own
brand yeah what's the name of your
company auric property so talk to me
about the in the early days some of the
struggles mentally between you know
because you've got people you know
normal people that go into property you
you know you've got friends and family
and work colleagues what are you doing
you must have had people saying what
you're mad
yeah especially when you you turn it
down a big pension they're like no just
play it safe continue in a job get your
pension what are you doing I mean it was
it was tough at home I think my parents
particularly could not understand the
logic you know you've got your pension
in three years you know they're trying
to look after my future
I was a real bit of pill to swallow but
they did support me they had their
concerns especially uh certainly friends
and our friends one in particular you
know instructed me to to go and get a
refund and that I was being had and that
it was all a big scheme I'll never
forget that did you believe it or did a
part of you believe it do you know what
I was worried but I think you know I did
have any concerns you should always be a
little bit wary but
there was something you said in one of
the meetings and it was sort of like 95
of Academy members achieve Financial
Freedom I was thinking surely you can't
lie about that you know like that that
was something that stood on me 95 and I
really wanted Financial Freedom yeah you
know and so I was all in
I think when you make the decision you
just needed to go yeah and commit and
yeah you've always got that niggling
feeling in the back of your mind what if
this doesn't work out when did you
realize that actually this does work
you've not been had there's no scammy
scheme no this is a legitimate
property professional property training
course it worked when did it click and
you're like this is actually I think
selling the first deal I think some
selling the first deal was like wow you
know seeing the money in the in the bank
um but a lot of it you learn yourself
because you have to implement your own
systems and procedures and you have to
have your own approach yeah you know
you've taught me how to get into the
business and you're there to help me
moving forward but I think you have to
develop your own systems and and be
known for
your your own Niche yeah be unique
otherwise if everyone's doing the exact
same thing you found your Niche with
housing associations the Northeast your
area you've got your way of doing things
um how long did it take from deciding to
go for it yeah and going on the courses
to selling your first deal so I think
that was a little bit of a slow burn and
it was because I was juggling the
military uh so for the first
three or four months maybe three and a
half months hours I was still in the
military and I found that very hard and
I think that's one of the challenges a
lot of Academy members face is they've
committed to the academy but they've got
essentially now two jobs yeah you know
in a family and in a life and it's
really hard to get going I think
whilst you're running the two jobs you
know there's there's nothing you can do
apart from graft yeah and that's where
you really need to want it yeah but then
eventually you can give one up and
pursue yeah you know and it is
especially I mean for some people that
I've got money if you've got a few
hundred thousand pounds and you join the
academy because you just want to learn
how to invest it that's a whole
different story but when you join the
academy and you're looking to do deal
sourcing and rent to rents and it's very
active isn't it yeah it's not passive
there's nothing passive about deal
sourcing no no I think deal sourcing in
particular I mean I've been engrossed in
Deal source and haven't looked at rent
to rents you know really I've been so
laser focused on Deal Source now
it does take a while you know you know
you know to to master your craft it
takes a while yeah and there's nothing
there's nothing wrong with that but I
think in terms of time I think it was
around that sort of three months Mark
yeah to to sell a deal and when you saw
that first deal how did you feel
a sigh of relief really a sigh of relief
and a and a hooked to build some
momentum and I did I sold another one in
Short succession uh so that was two and
and yeah really sort of pushed on from
there when you sold your first deal
how long would it take before quitting
the military when and how did you decide
to quit the military uh so it was sold
in around the November time yeah of last
year and I officially uh left the
military on the first of January so
about what six seven months ago now yeah
yeah so from the first of January so
this year has been my property Year
how's life different now from a year ago
oh my God I mean I mean last year for
example out deployed you know in support
of Ukraine you know and deployed and a
real collar around my neck weight sort
of chained down
I mean I've missed 800 days of my
daughter's life you know in terms of
sacrifice
I did I was so committed I was actually
a loyal serviceman and and I wanted to
stay in full term I wanted the pension
that was what my life was about I was a
military man
yet I was undervalued and underpaid I
was struggling to get promoted
and I was really quite
This Was Heard by that you know that
that was what I wanted to do I loved the
military but when you're feeling
squashed in and you know you you just
for your own sanity you need to do
something where you've got that
self-worth and I needed to have that
feeling like I was successful when you
first heard about deal setting
what what were your thoughts initially
Deal Salem is not the one for me when I
first found out about dealing when did
you find out how did it happen like was
it a course was it a YouTube video it
was YouTube so it was YouTube I remember
I remember watching the videos at the
start and thinking
Network and building an investor list
compliance social media
stop no no no no no no no no no
I think when you first start now deal
source and you think well hang on I'm
the advisor so I'm advising that I'm
also coordinating and people are
people are buying property based on what
you tell them yeah and I felt like it
was war you know you know surely not and
you are right though it is quite a big
responsibility you knew you can't watch
a YouTube video and then start making
you know seven loads of deals you need
to really know what you're talking about
yeah you do you need to be trained I
heard someone recently saying you know I
might do what you're doing deal source
and you know pretty easy you know Fast
Cash
yeah yeah that's sort of educated them
on really it's it's actually a role of
responsibility you know you need to take
it serious yeah and I think actually I
although there's lots of deal sources
out there I feel as though I stand out
yeah in that before you invested a lot
into education for a start if you're
getting on a plane and the pilot says
you know I've not done any training but
I've watched some YouTube videos you're
going to be very afraid and in the same
way you wouldn't put your life in the
hands of an untrained pilot why should
someone put their life savings into the
hands of a deal sourcer that won't even
invest two thousand pounds learning how
to understand the the the foundations of
the business you people want and you
have and you've worked extremely hard
how did you feel when you handed your
notice into the military
great it was a mixed feelings mixed
feelings because it was a huge risk yeah
huge risk you know I don't necessarily
like living on the edge I'm quite a safe
person really yeah I'm quite risk-averse
and to do that was a really big deal for
me
so
very proud himself very proud of himself
but it was an experience what do your
family think of what you're doing now
they're excited by it you know they're
excited about it my parents are actually
sort of at that pension age where
they're wondering what to do that the
the sat on an awful lot of equity uh
I've actually given them a bit of a
pension plan oh wow you know of how they
can enjoy the rest of their life and
although they're hesitating a little bit
I think I think yeah why do you think
people are so scared
to leave their job and get into business
or property Investments what do you
think it is that makes people feel so
hesitant because it took you
you were had to be pushed over the edge
really in the military if the military
being just a little bit of giving you a
small pay rise and giving you a little
bit more recognition you'd probably stay
there so they just pushed you a little
bit too much where you thought you know
what I'm done
but why do you think people are so
afraid to take that risk I suppose
because it's
huge sums of money I think a lot of
people aren't from money
so when you start
gambling with huge sums of money yeah
that makes them feel uneasy certainly in
a in an area that they're not educated
on yeah so I think
the the level of uh Financial commitment
sometimes can be the the main reason of
concern I guess it makes sense and if
you're if your parents had a paycheck
and their parents just had a monthly
paycheck it's against the grain isn't it
does that actually I'm gonna get into
property and sell deals what makes you
unique as a deal sourcer I actually care
I really want to set someone up with an
investment which is a success yeah I
don't just want to sell you a deal and
walk away every single dealer I sell I'm
involved with for six months that's the
level of commitment because of the
refurb and because of the refurb and
because I want to fill it with tenants I
want it to be a success right so the
vast majority of my deals are BR yeah so
I'll introduce them to the build team
we'll go through the whole design and
implementation phase you know the whole
project management service that I offer
so I'm involved throughout the refurb
and then on the back end I'm also
helping with refinance and internet
management and things like this are you
know I'm involved for quite some period
of time yeah and Albert Einstein he says
don't try and be successful try and be
valuable yeah and then the success will
follow do you think maybe some deal
sources are just trying to make a quick
book they're trying to sell as many
deals as they can but actually that's
short-sighted isn't it because if you're
thinking about the longevity of your
reputation and of your client base if
you if you've got a happy investor
they'll recommend you to all their their
friends they'll buy from you again and
again and again and again and I think
that's probably what you're doing you're
thinking about the long term absolutely
and I think when you first introduce
yourself to an investor one of my first
questions is you know what is your
experience level because if you're
dealing with someone who has never
invested before you naturally have to
help more you have to guide them all
yeah you know I'm not saying I would
never take on the responsibility of it
being a I would never say this is a sure
thing this is a guarantee yes however I
know if someone's done it before or
haven't what level and what level of
involvement I'll have and there's also
there's a time to walk away isn't there
like we've had many people that will say
actually you know what we don't now's
the right time because the investors got
completely unrealistic expectations
they'll if they ask questions like I am
I am guaranteed to get all my money out
there's no guarantees the market might
drop probably you might get down
valuated the definition of an investment
there's always an element of risk
otherwise it wouldn't be an investment
absolutely and I never I never promise
anything that but what I do
um is make them aware of of of of of the
process what's your intention of but I
know you just bought a Bri today
congrats what's your goal then within
buying your own properties because I
know you're using a lot of the money
you're making deal sourcing to pump into
your own portfolio yeah so I suppose my
skill set in social housing hmos was
noticed by a few Angel Investors yes
um they're now funding two
properties obviously you've got a couple
more in the pipeline going through so
we're actually buying it on a joint
venture agreement nice so two five bed
social housing here congrats because
that's what we said at the ACP yeah well
exactly so Russell's advice was to to
get involved in some flips yeah so I
went off and that was the no that was
the intention but the
so there's a there's a there's quite a
unique element to this in that
once we've finished the refurb and we've
achieved a HMO license on the property
we've
refurbed it to the right compliance
level for social housing we moved the
tenants in and have the lease signed the
long-term guaranteed rent lease we can
then sell the property based on a yield
to a cash investor
so some overseas cash investors will buy
property if it's going to fix down to
yield yeah so we work backwards off a 10
yield
and we can actually sell them at 168 168
000 pounds is what we can sell right
these five bed social housing hmos for
because I guess to some extent is like a
bit like a commercial valuation it is it
is it's not a commercial valuation
issued by your bank yes but it's when
you consider what overseas cash
investors are looking for yeah they're
looking for a fixed yield and a nice
strong yield that that's a 10 is a
relatively strong yield and we can make
massive profits on on flipping and from
their perspective a lot of these guys
they'll just buy cash so it doesn't even
matter if the books more evaluation is a
little bit lower because they're just
wanting a 10 yield they're overseas
they're pumping they've got massive
businesses they're pumping it in and
you're buying properties putting high
rent selling it to them is awesome we
can get into one of these deals for a
hundred and ten thousand pounds
approximately and sell it 168. what
about the reefer that's all in so one
one ten okay all Associated costs and
and then we can sell it 168 and there's
no estate agent selling fees or anything
like that straight to the straight to
the seller what is the moment you've
been most proud of over the last year I
I think
leaving full-time military leaving
full-time military to pursue
a life in property and actually becoming
successful at it and I'm actually very
proud of my reputation do you ever
repent yourself about how much money
you're making now yeah I hope this is
just the start I think 12 000 pounds is
a hell of an achievement but actually
the way that I'm forecasting the
companies how much do you expect to make
per month in the next six months I think
by month six we're going to be in excess
of twenty thousand what's your
experience been like I know on the
academy you wanted to quit after a few
months and we we told you not to and you
decided not to was that a good mistake
or was that a good a good thing was it a
mistake are you glad you stuck with it
the truth is the academy has changed my
life there's no other way of saying it
there's no other way of saying it my
life has transformed because I joined
the economy that's awesome you know and
I'm a much happier person I've got a
much more flexible life now I see my
daughter much more yeah I earn more and
you've helped your family you hurt your
sister out yeah and I love what I do you
know I've got a passion for it and I've
got an aptitude for it and I'm doing
something that I love tells me about
your sister's deal because that was
quite powerful yeah so my sister lives
in London about half an hour right from
here
and she's gone through a bit of a rough
time I was down for some Advanced
Training I was here for the week and we
went into rent to rent together we are
trained her up told her how to do it we
made hundreds of phone calls throughout
the week we dealt with lots of failures
and but together we secured a rent to
rent in Chelsea yeah and the feeling
that that gave my sister actually pulled
her out with a bit of a hole actually in
and filled a fuller confidence and and
actually doing it together was fantastic
it was a great experience but still but
getting it but actually does the process
you know she got a real kick out of it
and it really sort of like I said pulled
her out with a bit of a hole and my
sister and I are now looking to do
things together I mean I've just started
a management arm of the company so I now
do management I've got lots of
contractors on my books and I'm actually
filling these properties with
essentially it's an essay management
company well mate I'm so glad to see
what you've done and and you grow as a
person as well it's just it's just
awesome what would be your final piece
of advice for somebody that's wanting to
maybe transition from their job and get
into property full-time get started get
on the ladder yeah best pieces of advice
best piece of advice is find a niche
work hard Master it become a master of
your craft build your reputation tell
people what you're about and what you're
doing I am not a social media person by
any means but you have to use social
media the big difference between the
companies that are doing well and maybe
is the people that are struggling a
little bit asking they're not actually
telling people what to do that's the big
differences is social media is so
powerful you know tell people what
you're doing and just keep going throw
yourself into it as well really throw
yourself into it you've got to really
want it that's awesome well Ross massive
uh thank you for coming down to share
today and um I wish you all the very
best in the future and afford to
continue working with you that's
something
[Music]
thank you